bonjour brut
on va
commencer à Paris
tu me diras tu leur diras salut c'est
Juliette la petite que vous venez de
voir vous vous souvenez d'elle elle
s'appelle evanina elle a 9 ans et elle
habite depuis 3 ans dans un foyer pour
enfants je l'avais rencontré lors d'un
tournage que j'avais fait pour raconter
son quotidien dans ce foyer bah là il y
a moi avec mes deux poupées
là c'est un dessin que j'ai fait
de danseuse evanina c'est une petite
fille avec sa tête remplie de rêver
d'ambition mais tout le long du tournage
il y a un rêve en particulier qu'il
n'arrêtait pas de me répéter c'était
quoi tes plus grand rêve pour le futur
bah c'est de passer du temps avec ma
famille et de devenir danseuse son
histoire a touché beaucoup d'entre vous
et à la suite du reportage j'ai reçu
plein de super message mais il y en a un
en particulier qui m'a vraiment fait
plaisir
bonjour je viens de voir votre reportage
sur la maison d'enfants à Annecy et sur
la petite evanina qui rêve de devenir
danseuse et qui m'a beaucoup touchée je
suis danseuse étoile à l'Opéra de Paris
et je suis le passage à Annecy plusieurs
fois par an je serai ravie de rencontrer
evanina bien à vous Léonore Baulac ce
message je l'ai directement transféré
son éducatrice Lauréline qui a organisé
une rencontre entre Léonore et Vanina le
temps d'une après-midi au bord du lac
d'Annecy
la rencontre c'est méga bien passée mais
je me suis dit à la rentrée que ça
serait cool de pousser encore plus loin
l'expérience et de faire venir evanina
et son éducatrice Aurélie à Paris pour
visiter son lieu de rêve ultime l'Opéra
de Paris et du coup avec l'aide de
Léonore c'est exactement ce qu'on a fait
[Musique]
coucou là on va à l'hôtel on est où le
taxi de Paris
mon rêve d'aller à l'opéra de Paris
la réalité de Paris
[Musique]
c'est pas comme à la maison et
maintenant je peux regarder la télé
voilà la coiffure
enfin terminée alors Aurélie on part au
petit déj à l'hôtel
[Musique]
oui et même dans un film
ballerina ballerina c'est le film avec
lequel j'ai rêvé d'être danseuse
c'est un des plus beaux jours de ma vie
elle arrive
regarde là en bleu
tu as vu
je t'avais dit qu'elle était là
oui
ça a été le voyage oui super je te
montre mon bureau est-ce que tu as vu le
devant de l'Opéra oui en arrivant tu as
vu l'avant avec toutes les statues
arrière c'est là où les artistes
rentrent donc évidemment les danseurs
mais aussi les musiciens et puis tous
les techniciens les abeille
plein de monde en fait tu parles de
l'arrière qui est tout là-bas là-bas
là-bas là-bas
ou pas j'ai pas décidé alors il est
l'heure d'aller au cours pour
s'échauffer un peu
tu viens parce que OK
je crois qu'il sortait c'est tout petit
et pas très important en fait c'est
super important
surtout après plus tard quand tu feras
des pointes et ce machin du coup ça se
casse pas ça peut se casser et si ça se
casse et que ça me vient dans la figure
ça fait très mal
habituelle
on a un très bel opéra par contre ça
compense un peu
[Musique]
et surtout comment ils arrivent à suivre
comment ils arrivent à retenir ça
j'arrive même partout
[Musique]
les mêmes exercices mais c'était une
femme qui reviennent donc du coup on
apprend à reconnaître des automatismes
après il y a aussi une forme de mémoire
qui est exercée à force de faire ça tous
les jours donc il y a plein de trucs
pour lesquels j'ai pas une bonne mémoire
mais pour les exercices dedans ils sont
j'ai une bonne mémoire
c'est bon
où est-ce qu'on va on va au quatrième
ok
il y a des abeilles qui font du miel sur
le toit de l'eau elles sont elles sont
un peu planquées là-bas
on arrive dans un endroit très spécial
c'est le département des costumes parce
qu'en fait tous les costumes ils sont
fabriqués ici
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de choses
ils sont faits sur mesure à nos tailles
comme ça
je suis dans le paradis des costumes
ça tu vas sur les costumes de Raymonda
de quoi Raymond bassin tu as des
questions du Lac des cygnes ça c'est le
prince mais du coup c'est qui le
personnage principal dans le lac des
cygnes
c'est Odette le signe blanc et la même
danseuse dans ceci Odile le cygne noir
Odette c'est la princesse qui est
gentille et dont le prince ah oui Odette
ça me fait penser à mon film préféré ah
c'est quoi ton film ballerina ah c'est
ballerina tu sais que la méchante dans
ballerina un moment qu'elle danse avec
avec le personnage que tu préfères oui
et ben c'est moi qui ai fait la méchante
en fait je dansais avec une autre
danseuse étoile qui faisait la gentille
et moi je dansais la méchante et après
ils ont tout filmé et après ils ont fait
le dessin animé
j'aime bien cette couleur et elle aussi
je vais prendre lui avec lui
et le dernier
le dernier c'était lequel ah oui ici là
juste là j'arrive pas à le toucher
ouais
ouais juste il y a des techniciens qui
travaillent tous les dérangent pas et on
fait attention parce que parfois il
déplace des décors et tout ça donc c'est
un peu dangereux donc je reste avec ok
c'est parti
c'est tellement beau
et là tu vois
mettre 1800 personnes 1800 personnes
et l'entrée de l'Opéra elle ressemble à
quoi à ma l'entrée elle est très belle
mais si tu veux on ira même on ira par
un passage secret
en permanence parce que j'ai le micro et
du coup elle m'entends
le numéro 9 c'est ça exactement
je m'en suis souvenue je m'en suis
souvenu j'arrive pas à croire que je
suis dans l'Opéra de Paris par contre
l'Opéra de Paris je l'imaginais un peu
moins grand il est où le passage secret
du côté du public
c'est trop beau
là c'est d'où elles ont sauté comme ça
là avec les deux jambes et là c'est où
elle a fait le grand j'étais
toujours rêvé
d'être dans l'Opéra de Paris là juste
ici là
c'est trop beau
tu as trop de chance
dire que tu vis à moitié là-dedans
mais du coup c'est payant visiter
l'opéra et non
je pense que tu peux avoir des visites
payantes si tu veux aller de l'autre
côté justement du côté des artistes ça
c'est payant mais si tu veux juste
visiter ici normalement c'est grave
[Musique]
c'est Léonard
regarde
le roman du balai
elle est recouverte tu vois parce que
c'est en travaux
la statue dorée c'est celle que tu
voyais tout à l'heure de la fenêtre
c'est bien oui
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à la
rentrée evanina a été acceptée au
conservatoire de danse d'Annecy et du
coup pour marquer ce premier pas vers
son rêve Léonard lui a offert toute une
nouvelle tenue de danse soit elle
soit lui et
Aurélie tu dis que j'ai nickel le bleu
elle a dit
et bah c'est Juliette qui avait raison
merci beaucoup
et à une prochaine fois à une prochaine
fois oui voilà du coup j'espère que
cette visite de l'Opéra de Paris à
travers le regard d'un enfant vous a plu
pour ma part je vous dis au revoir car
c'était mon dernier sujet avec brut j'ai
adoré tourner tous mes reportages et
merci pour vos idées et vos messages et
surtout un énorme merci à mon équipe
incroyable sans qui aucun reportage
aurait été possible si jamais vous
voulez retrouver mes autres sujets ils
sont tous sur le Youtube de brut et
n'hésitez pas si mon Instagram pour voir
mes nouvelles aventures j'ai hâte de
vous montrer la suite et à très bientôt
bye